what you're looking at depending on who  you ask is either a revolution for the  internet and countless Industries as we  know it or the greatest Ponzi scheme in  human history  I promise that you can get rich for free  accused of being all of these things is  the world of cryptocurrencies all the  other labels associated with it nfts  blockchains web 3.0 from the bizarre  onslaught of celebrity promotions and  endorsements to the eye-watering numbers  and headlines I once described the world  of cryptocurrencies as a story in  hopeful optimistic tones now I don't  think it's the story that I initially  thought it was they only make money  because some other sucker lost more have  fun staying poor it amazes me that  anybody is buying into this they are  decentralized hanji schemes they only  think that you have to show is Ponzi  schemes it's all [ __ ]